today we're gonna show you some really
simple things and some more complex
things which we think you're all gonna
really appreciate using a vs code and by
the end of this talk we're hoping you're
all gonna say yeah vs code can do that
yes one of the things I love about this
slide is vs code we think of it as a
text editor but you need to think of
that spectrum as a slider you can
actually take a slider and move it
across that spectrum you could turn vs
code to do as much of an IDE as you want
it to be or just make it a simple text
editor the choice is yours and the man
the myth the legend one of his quotes
that I love here from the original
release of vs code it combines the
simplicity of a code editor with what
developers need to do their day-to-day
jobs Erich gamma created this tool along
with Chris Diaz and a bunch of other
great people on the vs code team so we
take these three pieces that they use to
put it together manat Monaco or Monaco
mano what did you call now Monaco deco
Minako Monica Monaco alright the right
way we take these three pieces that runs
with electron which allows us to the
desktop like experience inside of our
tool other great products also use
electron and then type scripts the type
script server in this case helping us
get all sorts of great coding features
even when we're not using typescript and
raising JavaScript so we take those
pieces and we put those together and
what we end up with is Visual Studio
code Burke that's right so Roger Minako
now powering Visual Studio code along
with the other pieces you've seen here
but the reason I told you that story
about Eric and in back in 2012 is
because eric is very famous for
something else
they didn't just hire a guy they hired a
guy with some experience does anybody
know what Eric was part of creating
prior to Visual Studio code gang a4 but
that's not what is looking for I do have
a Google cluster for the right answer
who said it I heard it somewhere in here
say it loud Eclipse flips that's right
so the same person who brought us
Eclipse has now brought us Visual Studio
code so the reason why they hired Eric
is because he had the expertise and the
knowledge to create developer tooling
and now as Paul Harvey would say you
know
the rest of the story that's right so my
name is Burke Holland this is real
studio code can do that I'm also known
as you might also know me as who never
heard of him and you are and I'm John
papa I'm just a guy who gets to stay
next to him and we look alike so that's
kind of good too right that's right you
get two bald guys for the price of one
second pictures are out there lucky you
oh yeah next slide there's me that's or
it's me either way and then there's
internship yep there we go you got both
of us everybody needs a doppelganger it
works out great for meetings over
skyping all right so let's move right
into it by the way before we get started
as Burke's cranking up here we have I
think just a couple tips to show you
like 90 so we're gonna try to get
through all these in this time and I've
got a bonus one at the end that I just
learned about this morning really yes
I'm scared or nothing like preparing a
demo five minutes before you get on
stage one of these buttons no don't
press those there's a red but I'm gonna
press the red button on the desk the
first thing that I want to talk about
with everybody is themes now you're
aware that Visual Studio code can do
themes I'm sure that everybody already
knows that but I want to talk to you
about a couple of different things that
you can do with themes so the first
thing is in our themes here you may know
or you may not know that there are two
kinds of themes that are light themes
and there are dark themes I personally
as you saw my my vyas code instance
flash by in a second I use a light theme
I like light colors I like a light theme
I use the theme called hoplite now I've
been told that using a light theme is
not good for your eyes according to
science but it is 2018 and I'm not
allowed about to let science or facts
stand in the way of my perfect editor
setup john prefers a dark theme here and
he's wrong and that's okay but he is
using one called winter is coming which
is a fantastic theme i'm gonna give you
some others that are also very popular
one is called the atom dark theme it's
very popular and then there's one let's
see if you have cobalt too you don't
have cobalt installed there's one from a
guy named Wes boss and it's called
cobalt 2 and cobalt 2 is interesting
because it is actually the best theme
according into science for your eyeballs
and so what it is is a dark blue back
with bright yellow text and that is
supposed to be easiest for you to look
at did we fix my uh try it right here
you got a hit what button do I hit
I think the buttons are good you there's
Cobalt ah there's cobalt ooh I'm gonna
try real quick you're there and then you
disappear then I'm gone
alright I hope you enjoyed that all
right so let's go to cobalt 2 okay thank
you see our themes here so we install
the theme here's cobalt 2 all right so
he's got already got it loaded here and
let's just take a look at some of the
files that we've got inside of here
let's go here Sean I can't navigate your
code there we go
so you can see that we have sort of a
bright yellow text on a dark blue
background let me do that for it okay go
ahead good we good yeah he's gonna get
on the cable for you okay perfect
another thing that you will want to do
for your BS code installation is you're
you don't want to tweak these icons over
here to the side so let's go ahead and
collapse these here there we go so you
can see we've got a bunch of different
icons over here for our files and we
zoom in on this you can see we got some
some angular you do angular a little bit
as anybody know that okay I think so but
the the icon theme that most people use
is quite popular it's called material
icons and material icons is really
really neat because there's a different
icon for every file type so for instance
if we added a file here so I'm just
gonna add a file to this folder I'm sure
you'll be fine with that John oh yeah no
problem completely broke your demo so
like a pug file and look what we get
yeah everybody wants to write pug files
now just so they can have a bunch of pug
faces in there editor I like to add just
some different file types just to see
what the icon is like do you need docker
no but I want to know what the file icon
looks like so I'm going to use it now so
material icons is another very very
popular editor theme the other thing
that I want to talk about when it comes
to the appearance of your editor is
something called font ligatures who in
here by a show of hands has heard of
font ligatures alright so a decent
number of people a decent number of
people have it if you have as totally
fine font ligatures are fonts that take
symbols that we use in programming
because we use a lot of compounds
bowls and it turns it into a single
symbol so do you have fun ligatures
installed on this machine I don't but
you can turn it on yeah fairy code
installed on this machine yes okay
excellent
so what we're gonna do first is you're
gonna go and you're gonna go to download
a file called fear of code now you won't
remember this it's okay it's in the
slides and fear of code is an open
source font it's on github you're gonna
download it it's a TrueType font file
you're gonna double click it hope to god
there's not a virus in there and that
it's gonna be installed to your machine
now once you have the file let's see
have you added this here user settings
already jungle okay so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna come down here to the
bottom and add in a couple settings here
so let's do first let's do editor dot
font family do that oh you already did
that yep I didn't have to look at
yourself yeah okay so and then we're
gonna do editor dot ligatures where is
it
see when you can't find a setting you
can come over here to the sign I just
search for ligatures that's not a spell
ligature right that's true font ligature
is right here we can just say yes set it
to true it automatically gets copied
over I don't know if everybody saw that
right there move this out of the way
there we go true and then we'll save
that and then once we save that our font
ligatures aren't enabled now it doesn't
look like anything here but when we go
back to our setting so let's go back to
this typescript file here and let's do
something like we have a new function
we'll just call this function bald looks
good and then this and then we'll do a
double arrow and when we do that double
arrow you'll see that turns into an
actual double arrow right and the same
thing works for like if you have a
double equals you get an actual double
equals if you do a triple equals because
in JavaScript we need three equal signs
equals equals equals you get an actual
triple equals so this is what the code
team uses they use font ligatures and it
just makes for a very very nice
development experience inside of you do
four equals you can't do four equals but
then you actually get 40 below which is
a little bit disappointing you can do an
arrow like that that works right so you
can just yeah now you want to use spot
ligatures and see all the different
things that you can use so those are
font like a church the other thing that
I want to show you in terms of
appearance is in your user settings you
can
change the way that your cursor looks so
let's go to cursors cursor there we go
see it says editor cursor Styles blank
so we can change this to something like
phase there we go and then let's come
over here John from your theme I can't
see your cursor it's there but you can't
see it look at that but that's not my
theme dude that's cobol's let's move but
winter is coming best theme in the world
you got to download it there we good
he's gonna try to fix yours okay cool so
you can change the the cursor style you
have there's a phase style there's a
blink style there's an expand style so
these are all the different things that
you can do to tweak the appearance of
your editor to make it your own with
your themes with your font icons with
your font ligature or excuse me icon
spot ligatures and the cursor style yes
alright so what are you doing Burke
touches your machine you immediately
undo everything he did sorry Burke that
should be a command and get like it
should just be out of the box should be
some get integration via - Burt if only
that existed so something I want to show
you is if we go to code Visual Studio
comm it's something not a lot of people
know or maybe you know it but you
haven't tried it yet is when you go to
the code website one of the best-kept
secrets is that you can download this
with a stable Bill Reese improbable do
here but there's also an insider's build
how many people here use the insiders
book and I see a show of hands that's a
good amount but the rest of you haven't
tried it yet I'm gonna tell you the
reason I use insiders and I use it every
single day and I've used it every day
since it came out is because with
insiders you're generally getting
nightly builds they're very very stable
for me I've had maybe two days in the
last three years where it didn't work
total and I flip back to the stable is
that you can have stable insiders
side-by-side but with the insiders
you're getting almost daily updates of
new features and some of the things
we'll show you today we're actually only
in the insiders which is pretty wicked
cool including the bonus at the end so
if you want the insiders you click the
button you choose hey I want insiders
comes over here and it takes really a
long time to download like eight seconds
and then it's on your machine and then
you can just open it up and you can have
insiders and regular
so here I've got the insiders on my
machine there but I can also open up
code side by side and if you're into
this you can have two different themes
running in both of them so definitely
something to check out so once you
install code one of the things that a
lot of people like to do is they like to
be in some kind of a terminal and maybe
in the terminal they'll go ahead and
they want to be in a folder like I've
got this folder called play and in there
I've got a folder called node 101 and
maybe I want to open up an instance of
code well you can actually set it up so
you can have a key command here that
opens up code
I've set up a bash command so I can open
up code by typing C dot by default
Visual Studio will a code will allow you
to do this so if I hit C dot here up
pops code insiders which is my default
with that project right in the same
machine this is super handy I use this
all the time there's probably one tip
you should take so far it's that one
right there
now I'm going to show you our favorite
command and Burke if they don't remember
anything today what do they have to
remember command PP command shift P
command shift P yes I'm doing command P
P that's an actual thing we'll get to it
in a second yes command PP is great to
command shift P if you forget anything
in vs code brings up the command palette
and you can type things in there for
example you can type in path so you can
say shell command install code insiders
in the command path that will allow you
to type code - insiders in your terminal
to open up code or in the stable version
of code or Lyda type code in terminal
and open up whatever folder you're in
inside of Visual Studio code so I've
already done that on my machine so
that's where I am cool and that's super
helpful because when people tell me
they're like Burke just put it in your
bash profile I'm like I don't know what
that is
but I can go to the command palette and
just click a menu entry I'm like look
I'm just like you I know all about the
terminal are you just like me Burke well
I'm not just like you
so there's another cool feature that
decided vs code that I want to show you
all cuz sometimes new features come out
and it's hard to keep up with things if
you go to command palette again command
shift P and I type in playground there
is an interactive playground that you
can bring up in the interactive
playground allows you to learn some of
the new features and not only read about
them but see them in action and try them
right here so I could go down to
background and I can highlight using a
multi cursor and I can type in Burke
loves bacon like that and I can learn
how to use features right inside of this
playground right here in vs code if you
haven't been through that interactive
playground I highly encourage you to go
through it every line in there you'll be
surprised at how much you can master
just from going through that interactive
tutorial now before we get too much
further and tips inside of us code I
want to show you a couple things that
you're gonna see quite a bit for example
you've seen us already have things like
these different windows up in our
machines hey let me open a folder I'm
going to type in my password it's 1 2 3
4 5 6 don't remember that please very
it's so secure John I am very secure so
here's a folder and let's say I'm inside
my project and I've got this open over
there and I've got this open over here
it gets like a little crowded sometimes
you're gonna see different things happen
the thing on the left over here that's
our sidebar this Explorer I can make a
common go pretty quickly with the
command key stroke and works gonna show
you that in a moment this thing in the
bottom that is our bottom part and in
there we've got our terminal and our
output and other things we can make that
come and go we can also see we've got
multiple files going on you can have
multiple files and multiple panes for
example let's say I had index on this
side and package.json over here I can
actually change the cursor by hitting
command one or command two going back
and forth between those two different
files let's say I wanted to maximize
looking at my package JSON I can drag it
all the way over and I can maximize it
now if I hit command 1 I want to see
everything in the index file it
automatically snaps over it shows
maximized view of the other pane so I
can make them do push-ups like this and
they can fight each other and I can do
command 3 and go to another file this
project doesn't have a lot of files yep
there we go but we can do it that way
and as long as you drag one pane all the
way to the side one split bar now as you
go through them you'll see how they
maximize as best they can
how do you close a single file command W
command W command W and my favorite
command personally is command PP so
whenever you want it to go back to the S
file you do command PP so I'm inside of
index J s now I had what filed before
package.json what if I want to go back
to
man to the index J s my old command I at
p1 speech Weiss let go and it goes back
so anytime you have to go what do you do
command P P alright so we showed you
kind of all those do there another cool
thing is and this is a feature and
sublime that's had for a while and nvs
codes got it as well have you ever just
needed to write notes real quick like I
say you know what don't forget to tell
Burke to shave his head you know you've
got something like that yes headers
don't forget to tell Burke to shatters
now I haven't saved this file how do I
know that because it's got untitled one
and there's this big circle up there
which is a universal symbol for you
didn't do what you're supposed to do so
in that file I didn't do that well if I
close vs code it's like uh-oh what
happened did I lose that now if I open
it back up let's see what happens I'll
zoom in a little the file still there
this is because there's a feature turn
on a vs code called hot save so if I go
down here there's a hot exit feature and
I turned this on as Burke shows for
foreign settings I can click on this I
can say on exit or on Windows close you
can see over on the right I've got mine
set to on exit which allows me to save
that file some people like this feature
in vegan webstorm and in Visual Studio
it's called mini-map there's a thing
here called a editor mini-map but I've
got mine turned on to true so if I open
up a file like index J s and let's go to
a mini-map right there we'll set it to
true I come back over you can see over
here on the right there's like a
mini-map of that file lets you scroll
through it I happen to like my screen
real estate so I keep mine off you just
change that inside of your editor and it
just instantly disappears other stuff
that you can do Burke already showed us
how we can do font family so you can
type in font family you can put them in
here notice that my font family is right
now for your code I happen to like
operator mono all you have to do is put
it in the right order and you can do it
that way they'll change that sequence if
you want to get kind of crazy you can
pick one like architect's daughter and
then your code oh it's not installed in
this machine it's not installed it was a
fall to the second one but your code
will switch to whatever one is actually
machine starting at the left moving over
to the right got a long list of fonts
there man
I do I'd like to play with fonts I like
the end console this one it sounds like
the sad font doesn't it it's
inconsolable that's a terrible joke yes
welcome so the last thing I want to show
you is a feature I like a lot of times I
want to get things out of my way well
there's a feature called Zen mode if you
type in Zen inside the command palette
and you go hit that everything else
disappears but your code which is super
cool you can still get to everything
else so I can flip around my code and do
what I need to do with command PP and
get back there and what I want to get
back out of it I just go back up the
command palette which is command shift P
and I can toggle the mode and get right
back out nice so now the moment of truth
is Burke's computer finally gonna work
let's see it's just not meant to be I
should have got a PC that's the problem
all right then this will be interesting
let's just keep right on going yeah I'm
gonna just gonna mess your demos up from
start to finish that's fantastic there
just be a downhill slide all the way
okay it yeah it let's see that's that's
a good question I may have a Google
cluster for you if that's correct
let's try extend go back over again
let's try to get go back over oh no nope
here maybe here right there
nope denied just not happening all right
no problem
so I'll tell you what let's just do this
we'll continue over here on yeah I don't
know that I have that connector type
that okay all right they have a Mac and
so you need a dongle to do anything at
all
I have it's not only we knew something
about technology I know
exactly are there any developers in the
room is there a doctor in the house so
let's do this let's come over to one of
your projects here do me a favor John if
you would pull up a one of your fabulous
angular files that's got more than one
or two functions in it so we can take a
look at how we can use navigation to go
through some more complex code files so
one of the ones that you can use that's
really really nice we talked about the
command palette which is command shift P
is you can use the command palette to
navigate through your code and there's a
couple different ways that you can do
this so first you to do command shift P
and that's gonna bring up the command
palette and you'll see here that we have
a relatively long file there's just a
lot going on here and the longer your
file gets the harder is to navigate
through so what you can do is you new
command shift P and then you can use the
@ sign here excuse me the at that sorry
that would be command P and then the @
sign and that's gonna just organize your
code here into the different places like
your methods and properties so you can
just move between them now G Mouse
through you can go to the different
items in your code here if you use a
colon here like this it will now
organize your class's methods and
properties and group them up here in the
command palette so you can easily jump
between them another thing that you can
do is you can just use the colon and
that actually allows you to jump
directly to a line number and it tells
you how many line numbers you have so
you can go to so when you go to line 32
we just took 32 and boom we navigate
automatically to line 32 so that's
navigating from the command palette with
the symbols if you forget what those are
it's okay you can do command P and then
you can just do a question mark and it
will tell you here are all of the things
you can do inside of this to navigate to
your code and that's just right there
another thing that you're going to want
to do and John did this before but we
should talk about this is if there's one
another keyboard shortcut you remember
besides command shift P it would be
command B and all that does is toggle
the side bar it's a very simple one but
these are the fundamentals you're
definitely going to want to know how to
do that so that you can toggle the side
bar in and out there let's do let's talk
about this lower pane so John talked
about the lower pane he showed you where
it was on the bottom there this is
something that you're going to use a lot
because there's a lot of stuff in there
the terminal is in there the debug
console the output window is in there
and there are a couple different ways
that you can navigate in and out of this
section one of them is you can just
navigate directly to the terminal and to
do that you use the control backtick
which is that the little key above the
the tab there I was like to say it's the
key I didn't it was on my keyboard
right you're like what is that I think
it's called it Tildy so the control till
the key and that will toggle you
directly to the terminal now there's
another way to get to this part of the
editor that's a little bit more useful
if you'll notice here if I come over to
problems and I click on this of course
there are no problems because it's your
code and it's all I know you're just
amazing too but that's how good you are
if I control back tick out of this and
I'm like oh I want to it took me to the
terminal it's not exactly what I wanted
so if you want to just toggle the bottom
screen instead of moving to the terminal
you can use command J and command J
toggles the window down and then toggles
it right back up again and it also
remembers where you are so if you're on
the problem screen if you do command J
it brings it down command J brings it
right back up and you're still on
problems so it's a good one to know
because you're going to be in that
bottom section all the time another
thing that we can do is we can hide
different parts of the editor that we
may not want to see so in this case and
it looks like John you've already hidden
your open editors here yes already got
that so you'll notice that John if you
use visual studio code before there's a
setting or a panel that'll be up here at
the top
let's just go to user settings here and
see if we can find the one and there's
open editors I think is what it's called
mm-hmm right yep open editors so he's
got open headers visible he's got nine
so let's go replace in settings and
let's change this right here where is it
at OMB command B let's see here there we
go
you got to remember how to collapse the
sidebar here so open editors wouldn't
put it at the bottom there where to go
where to go
too many settings too many settings
alphabetical is that what it is see
there it is thank you so much I have
another Google cluster for whoever
shouted that ounce so we can set this
too if we set this to zero this will
hide the open editors which is over here
on the side now John's already done that
so you don't see it but a lot of times
if you use BS code before you know that
it's up there and if you don't want to
see that I personally don't use that
open editor section a lot you can use
this tweak inside of your settings file
to go ahead and get rid of that so that
you don't have to see that again this is
all about just customizing vs codes
looks exactly the way that you want it
to look so that's open editors inside of
es code another thing that you can do is
you can hide recommended extensions so
if we go over here to our extensions and
John's already doing this is what John
you've got your vs code setup configured
on all correctly and all good I don't
have any tips here so let's do
recommended extensions I think it's
cause it recommended yep recommended
extensions you can also type pick ext at
the end of it does a fuzzy search Oh
does it oh okay
recommended ext there we go
we're where we are here editor you
recommend recommends the recommended
extensions ignore recommendations and
then there's extensions show
recommendations only on demand so if we
click this and we set this to true or
excuse me let's said it's a false and
then save and what that should do is
show our recommended extensions over
here on the side and it's not popping up
but usually you have a recommended
extension setting right there on the
left hand side and when you set that
setting it no longer shows the
recommended extensions panel and again
that's just giving you more real estate
on the left hand side so that you can
successfully use your code editor the
way that you would like to do it the
last thing I want to show you here
before I turn back over to John is
something called code folding code
folding is a very very helpful thing I
use this a lot in HTML so you see these
pluses and minuses over here on the side
we can collapse these different sections
like this in our code to give us more
room so if you have a large chunk of
markup like let's say you're using a
bootstrap nav bar because it's
scientifically true that you cannot
build a web application without
bootstrap so you're using bootstrap you
want to collapse something like that yes
it's perfect so you can collapse over
here like this and then you get more
more screen real estate you can also
toggle this from the command palette and
how do we open the command palette
command shift P man shift P yes that's
the one thing we should ask this every
five minutes command shift P I'm gonna
be checking it at the ER lines today
going sir can I see your ID yes come
chippie right exactly so you can toggle
here if we toggle let's see here let's
do folding and we can actually fold
everything we can fold all and that will
fold everything on the screen right so
it'll fold all of it in all the
different depths and you can also fold
at specific depths you can see here it's
folded all the way down you can fold it
recursively
so the code folding available through
the command palette a very powerful way
to collapse the code and have only what
you need on the screen when you need it
here's a bonus tip for code folding
notice when Burke folded the code up
here you know what's going on because
you see the line numbers you can play
tricks on your friends by turning off
line numbers in vs code and then it
looks like you just deleted all their
HTML on them that'll make them really
happy
you can tell what we'd like to do around
the office all right something else you
can do inside of here imagine that
you're looking at your code and you want
to mess with your friends heads which
you can tell we do quite a bit of
there's a nice feature called
line-height that i like to play with so
if you go to line-height if you just
click on the pencil on the left it's
gonna show me right where it isn't the
right so remember what Burke was looking
for it over here he knows that when you
click over here it goes right over to
there I've got mine set to zero but what
happens if I set this thing to one who
says hey long files of a thousand lines
of JavaScript so much code on the screen
this way yeah
come code with me everybody all right
and how do you get out of there cuz like
I can't see the setting I'm gonna teach
you a button you've probably never heard
of it's control-z thank God that worked
all right so we're back in our editor
something else and we mentioned this
earlier that we both use quite a bit as
the embedded terminal Berk opened it up
with the control tick a lot of times
I'll be using a terminal and we can zoom
in over here ooh my settings are broken
what did you do my settings sometimes
your settings are fixed them I made them
better I'm going to change you to a
light theme and you'll be good to go
awesome well thank me later so I can
type things my terminal down below and I
can see stuff over here I can also open
up a second terminal in here part way I
can do that is a the plus sign right
there that says John open a terminal and
then you can tells me the terminal cause
you can see in the drop down list
there's two zsh terminals that i've got
going on so this one I could do
something like go to CD inside my
terminal I can flip back over here to
the first one I can kill them both by
throwing them in the trash can but what
if I don't like to hit the buttons and I
want to use the keystrokes inside of
here with the control tick I can also
hit command slash command slash gives me
a second terminal on the right sometimes
you're working with node and you're
running a process on one side and then
you need a second terminal so this way
you can open two terminals if you want
or if you're like Burke you could open
up three or four or five or I don't know
how many more terminals and eventually
it does something like this which I
don't know how you would ever possibly
read all those terminals but they're
there at this point and how do you get
rid of all those that you can if you
want to
who doesn't want 42 terminals inside of
es code come on I do wow how many did I
actually create look at that alright so
back in here what could I possibly do
let's say that I wanted to run the
matrix over here so I could run the
matrix inside of the terminal
what happens if let's say I've got some
kind of a file open like this and now I
can't really see what's going on in the
file up there but let's say my terminal
was small and I wanted to see more of
what's in the terminal command shift P I
can toggle maximized panel and it's
going to give me a little more space now
command shift P it remembers the last
command I just hit enter and it goes
back down so whenever you just need a
little more space your terminal you can
toggle maximized panel and then make it
go back down
so let's toggle it back up come back in
here and I'm gonna open up a second
terminal on the right and then over here
I'm gonna use Burke's favorite thing
cows a Berk and you can run two
different things side by side inside
your code hmm
this is do it in Starbucks everybody I
think you're super cool yes guys mr.
robot anybody watch that show yeah it's
a great show I'll they go out super
depressing after season one and also
it's Christian Slater's not real
he's not real no a man he imagines him
did I just spoiler alert oh so sorry
I'll be live-streaming this just like to
apologize to everyone on the Internet
terrible this is my life everybody yes
this is what you get when you get to
work with me I I text you spoilers the
middle the day so something else that
you've really should learn about which I
find really super helpful is sometimes
you're like you know what I'm you
stating a certain keystroke combination
inside of code and it are inside of
other tools and it just works for
example let's say you're on Twitter or
another page like this and you're like
you know I just want to refresh my
screen Hey look there's my buddy max and
if I want to refresh inside the browser
without touching the the mouse or the
trackpad how do you do that f5 or
command R so my case I hit command R
Allah and it's refreshing Twitter hey
there's Simona hi Simona you're also on
the big screen and inside of es code
remember we said that V s code is
actually an electron app that's running
basically web code inside of it so it's
effectively like a browser so sometimes
you're like you know what I changed some
settings and things aren't really
working right and I just instead of
closing and reopening it what you can do
is go to command shift P you can type in
reload window and you can select it well
I didn't like doing that cuz it's
command shift P its type reload then hit
enter I wanted to do is map it to my own
keystroke of command R so I hit command
R and it reloads vs code for me how did
I do that though what I did is I went up
to the key bindings keyboard and I go
into let's go to the file and you're
gonna see all the available key bindings
are on the left and the ones that I have
mapped for myself are
on the right and I mapped command R to
reload my window whenever the editor has
focus and you can do all sorts of stuff
like you can see here like killing all
my terminal windows I've got that there
you can switch all your code to
uppercase with command shift u I do a
zoom reset every in the browser Jever
zooming in our browser like this or zoom
out let's go see Simona's face really up
close
there you are Simona sorry so there's
two motors face but in a browser you can
hit command 0 right inside of es code
doesn't work by default but you could
come into here and zoom in and then it
command 0 and I gotta get rid of your
bug whatever you put in there but then
it would set it back to 0 Burke we're up
to tip 42 nice alright so we're gonna
try one more time and I'm praying
somebody send in the AV gods to rescue
me please what's that it could be let's
try that one switch back John here and
let me just try to fix it again real
quick let's see here let's go to
settings see if we can change the
resolution let's go to scale let's do
1600 by 900 nope that's not gonna do it
1280 by 720 400 by 600 alright alright
alright it just wasn't meant to be
alright so the next thing that I want to
talk to you about is something called
init who in this room has heard of image
just by a show of hands okay a few
people several people haven't as totally
fine again we're all at different places
learning how to do different things with
our editors with our code so Emmet is a
way for you to compose markup very
quickly without having to use angle
brackets so John if you could open me an
HTML file or create me a new one that'd
be great
you want a new one a new one would be
favorite here's a news file yeah let's
start from scratch let's save this Burk
as HTML Burke you're now an HTML file
excellent alright so we have an HTML
file here and normally the way we'd
create markup is open angle bracket type
div and that Visual Studio code is smart
enough to know what we're
it'll automatically close this div for
us but there's a quicker way to do this
what we can do is we can just type div
and then hit tab and it will do the same
thing another thing that we can do is we
can you assign classes and ID's this way
as well so if we had a div with an ID of
main and a class of also main you can
see here that we have a tooltip and we
have an abbreviation and you can see
that's what it's gonna do when we expand
so I'll hit tab and we get that exact
expansion now you can compose a lot of
complex markup exactly this way so if we
come over here and let's do something
like this so let's do div dot navbar
because again we've already discussed
how you cannot build an app without
bootstrap and then inside of that navbar
we've got another div and it's got
navbar items let's do like this and then
maybe at the same level there's a ul and
inside of that there's an Li and let's
say there's three of them and let's go
ahead and tab and then you can see that
it expands all of that out with type of
animate there and then you can tab
through each one of these and enter in
the things that you would like for your
list items to have so that's one way to
use Emmet
now you can also use Emmet inside of
files like typescript files view files
and react files as well because react
tests JSX
angular has templates but you can also
write it inside have the angular file
and view files just end with view now
and it doesn't work out of the box in
those files but we can add in language
mappings for those things to make sure
that they work so we're back in user
settings here and by the way when we do
toggle into user settings that's command
comma is how we do that and then we can
come here and we can say again Emmitt
dot include languages right here and
then we can just start mapping so you
can see right here it has markdown so we
can map markdown to a type that vyas
code knows about so it could be
something like HTML and now Emmet will
work inside of markdown files we can do
the same thing like we wanted it to work
in angular we come over here we'd say
typescript
because that's when angular files are
and we can map that to an HTML file type
just like this I'm sorry
Oh x.x kilometers should be include
languages right here thank you very much
I do have a Google cluster for you as
well include languages so that's the way
that works and so you can add in
JavaScript and for JavaScript react and
for view files as well so that's how you
make that work in the different files
that you've got yep there we go let's
pull that out so let's do this let's
come back over here to my personally
named HTML file and inside of this I
want to show you some of the other
things that Emmet can do so let's go to
the Internet and let's get one of these
well you can't copy a picture from
Google can you do have any pictures in
this current project here you have like
a an assets folder with some images in
it perhaps and by the way to find out if
you got any pictures or images all you
have to do is a command P and then type
in jpg Oh
nice line all your images alright as a
picture of me very tiny and it's a tiny
picture of you alright so we can see
that this file here JP jpg is 32 by 32 I
don't know if you can see this will zoom
in so you see it's 32 by 32 now a lot of
times we're recreating markup here so
let's do Emmet you could do a whole page
of market with image by just hitting
exclamation mark tab and then you get a
whole page of markup so inside of this
let's say that we're creating an image
tag here so let's do IMG tab and then
here we would put our image source so we
can put I think it was SRC what was it
John
dot slash SRC yeah where you where your
image is at let's find out we'll go back
there it's in source assets source
assets so we should be able to just do
SRC assets is that the right path do I
have that right yeah I don't think
that's right because visual studio code
would pick that up looks like we're
gonna have to go up to up right there
app and then inside app assets right
there so we're gonna have to go up a
couple levels so let's just keep doing
that until we find it here which is a
really nice thing about vs code is that
you can just go up and it shows you
here's your folders so go up again
here's our other folders so we should be
able to come down and one more yep let's
do dot dot slash and we go to assets and
here's all of our images inside I think
we said J
P jpg there we go but what you're going
to want to do with your image tags is
you always want to add a width and a
height to your image tag because if you
don't when you go to render this in the
browser it's gonna render it's it's not
going to reserve the space on the page
for it and one of the things that's
always a pain for me is that I don't
know how big my images are so then I
have to go find out and then manually
put them in and so I tend to just not do
it so one of the things that Emmett will
do for you is automatically update the
size of your image in your markup so for
instance all we have to do is come here
at the end of the tag command shift P
correct
only one person command shift P and then
I will do update image size like this on
Emmet hit enter and boom you can see
right there wid thirty-two height 32 it
automatically brings it in now this is a
really really cool tip because this
doesn't just work inside of your project
with local small pictures of John's head
this also works with images that are out
on the internet so if you're referencing
a file via a URL this will work there as
well another place that it will work is
inside of CSS so if you're setting a
background image and you have a local
file or a remote file you can specify
that and it will automatically update
your image size so there's no more
excuse to have image tags without an
image size and emmitt can do that for
you another thing that Emmett can do is
it could just straight up do math so if
we had let's do let's say we had 1000
times 2.3 for time divided by 10 we can
highlight this right here and just say
Emmett math you just type math evaluate
expression and boom it evaluates the
expression for you so you don't if if
you're if you're using a calculator
along with Visual Studio code you really
don't need to do that you can do all of
this right inside of the editor and a
lot of this most of this is powered by
image you're not gonna remember all of
the image shortcuts and abbreviations
that's okay there is a cheat sheet for
Emmett that you can go out on the
internet just google it and what I would
do is just print it out and then just
start using it as best you can and then
you'll begin to learn the shortcuts as
you go along and you'll be a much more
productive developer
yes cool get undo all changes I didn't
know I had a tiny picture of me there
that's like really weird Mike why is
that there it's like the favicon aresome
no probably yes
that's what I need is your picture on
all my brothers that I was at an event
recently and it was a Viking so my
little tiny figures or if you know word
Bella's you get a nice little picture
award bell in there all right so what
comes up next organizing in ports one of
the things I like to do inside my code
is I like to have this is a hero's
application and you listen to a pattern
matching here looking for files I know I
have a file that's the types of good
file and it begins with the word hero
and I know it's like got lists in it
somewhere so I could type in hero list
like this and notice it's doing a
pattern match even though the dash
wasn't in there let's say you don't know
how to spell hero you just say it's her
list you can find it here I do this a
lot I can say I know there's an HTML
file called hero list somewhere I can go
find that pretty easily too so it's a
very very quick way to find your files
command P patch
partial file matching and I can go check
out a file now when I scroll back out of
here and let's go find a file that's got
more stuff in it I think this one has a
couple imports at the top let's say that
in your file you've got a lot of spaces
going on you've got multiple lines
somebody got to your code and this is
probably really upsetting Burk I know
he's got like a big problem with spacing
so tabs or spaces
that's Thank You Vera single tabs I'm so
proud of everybody here I heard someone
to say stabs single quotes or double
quotes single single quotes yes wow
we're all on the same page I like it so
let's say you've got your code in here
and you're looking at it if you press
save watches can happen my code dupe
puts it up there there's a feature
called organized imports it does not
make that noise that was me I don't want
to use it then yes exactly
if you type in Oregon it will find
different features over here on the side
it's not fighting over there let's go
find them
why is it not finding them do to do to
do
well there's a feature in their gold
organized imports so we can go in there
and set that feature on it will
automatically get reader whitespace it
will format it using whatever formatting
code settings you have in your project
which we'll look at next and it will
alphabetize the imports inside your code
you can also turn that off if you want
to this is a feature that I believe
Brian Clark is this in the stable yet
yes it just hits table recently correct
organized imports if you're wondering
I'm asking Brian Clark up here does a
monthly release on a vs code which is
one of our tips that we do yeah you
should check that out it's only two
minutes long so in two minutes you can
get all of the newest features of the BS
code and BS code ships a lot of new
features every month so by the time you
watch this two month from now you know
half the features that are new you won't
know about so you definitely want to
check out those videos so that you can
stay up to date on that so Google Brian
Clark and v/s code and you will find
those one of the things I like to use is
prettier so who has fights at their
office a lot on oh you know I don't like
what you form out of the code I like 80
character whist I like 120
I like commas I like semicolons I like
Burke I like John I mean that happens it
drops a lot if you don't want to fight
about this stuff use a formatting tool
like prettier prettier is a tool that's
very well used on the web and it allows
you to set up your own formatting
structure so there's a file that you can
create called a prettier RC file in your
project I don't have one because I use
the defaults but there's an extension
you can download so if you go prettier
over here and I'll make this a little
wider you can see the code formatter
here it's only got two million downloads
so a few of you obviously need to go
grab it too when you installs your
machine it'll use a bunch of settings
you can use a prettier RC file which is
just JSON where you can change it from
max character with max line was from 80
to 120 to 150 whatever makes you happy
spacing around brackets and things it's
really really nice it you check that
into your source control and then you
have no more fights on your team about
who's gonna format what anymore right
but you can still fight about jason vs.
jason Jason or JSON Jason it's Jason who
said JSON the a is implied you can't
make it you can't make up pronunciations
I just did we're
have a debate about all of this stuff
later on at the channel 9 stage this
afternoon where we're gonna talk about
all of these different very important
developer problems that have to be
solved right now yes like how you all
mispronounced Jason just like that
that would be a nice thing to see
everybody do the other thing that I want
to show everybody here is we are also
doing format code so how do you format
your code if you do format like this you
have options for formatting on paste
formatting unsaved you've also got a
formatting timeout that you can wait for
it I like to have a format code setting
in my project but if you forget these
things command shift P you type in
format document and you can see the
keystroke to go do that and that will
format your country your document based
upon your prettier settings or any other
settings you have inside of your project
now Burke there's one bonus that we
should mention here notice that every
time that I type some code in here there
is no little circle in the upper tab
didn't I mention earlier that there's a
little circle there and anytime you
change your file you haven't saved it
have you ever written code and then run
it and you're looking at it you're like
why isn't this taking effect because you
didn't save the file and usually takes
you a couple minutes to realize that
there's a nice setting that you can set
in the menu file autosave and I like to
check that on why because I do a lot of
demos and a lot of coding and I don't
want to have to command ass all day long
so with autosave it'll automatically
save my code on a delay what kind of
delay does it have well if you type in
autosave you'll see down here oops
there's an autosave by default it's off
you can turn that on so if I click on
this you'll see where mine set over here
mine's after a delay what is my delay it
is 1,000 years
those are milliseconds so after 1000
milliseconds it's automatically gonna
save my code and I love to do this
especially in JavaScript a node so it
saves my files my tests will rerun or my
angular review project will
automatically rebuild and just launch
inside the browser back to you Burke
nice all right the other thing I want to
talk about in vs code is intellisense
now I'm sure most people are aware that
vs code has intellisense obviou
telethons has been around for a while I
did hear somewhere that sublime text was
the first one I thought was Visual
Studio but
first one to do and tell us since I may
be wrong but one of the places that you
may not know that vs code can do
intellisense is in Jason Jason files it
works in Jason files it also works in
JSON files so let's go over to do our
user settings so we've been in this file
a lot today and that we've got tons of
user settings you picked up one thing
it's that you're gonna you're gonna
tweak user settings a lot so let's come
down and when we're looking for another
setting we can hit the quotes like this
and then all of our settings appear over
here to the side so vs code knows about
what all the settings are and then it
also knows what all of the options are
on this side and this is powered by the
intellisense envious code now this may
not be much of a surprise to you but
this also works in places that you
wouldn't normally expect and in ways
that you might not normally expect so
let's do this let's take this out go
ahead and save that mess your project up
royally and then let's look for a
package.json I'm sure you've got one of
those all right we got our package Jason
open you got it quite a few things in
here John one of the things though that
you probably don't know about vs code is
that intellisense works inside of
package JSON files so yes it works for
stuff up here like this where you have
your name and your license and the
scripts and the repo so you just quotes
and it'll tell you what all those things
are
you're not gonna fill them out anyway so
that's fine so let's just go ahead and
take this off I like it when you
initialize a new NPM project and it's
like author repo description and then
you just go through all of it and then
it says tests and it's like none because
I don't need any tests in my project so
just none why does it ask you about
tests what are tests
yeah exactly tests are for demos not for
real life all right so let's go down
under dependencies here and one of the
things I want to show you is under
dependencies we've got all of our NPM
packages now you don't normally hand
edit your package JSON file normally you
npm install you pull in a package but if
you had to for some reason I find myself
every now and again needing to hand edit
this file you can come down here and if
you press ctrl spacebar it will go out
to NPM
and it will look at all the different
package packages that are available so
obviously we're gonna want to use
CoffeeScript because it's 2011 and so
we're gonna want CoffeeScript but what
version of CoffeeScript do we need well
we don't know at this point you'd have
to open a browser go out to NPM check
what the current version is you don't
know you all you need a squiggly do I
need that carrot what the heck did those
things even mean nobody knows but you
can let vs code handle this for you by
coming in here to the quotes and hitting
ctrl spacebar and it will automatically
go out to NPM and detect the latest
version of the package this is a really
really powerful tool because it allows
you to keep context and stay where you
are inside of your editor without having
to bounce around to check different
things and again you can summon
intellisense at any time with ctrl
spacebar so this works right inside of
jason files this is NPM intellisense
while we're talking about NPM I also
want to talk about something from Erich
gamma we've mentioned him a couple of
times he wrote a package called NPM so
you can install an extension called the
NPM extension from a gamma and that does
a lot of different things like it adds a
bunch of options menu options to your
editor so you can if you type in NPM you
can see that I've now got run install
dependencies and then it also has all of
my NPM scripts right here within the
command palette so I can run a build I
can run tests I can just do run start so
you can control all of your NPM actions
directly from here the other thing that
it will do is that it's very very smart
about knowing which packages you have
and are using in your project and if you
have a discrepancy in your package JSON
file I see you've upgraded to angular 6
I have how did that go well wonderful
all right so I'm just gonna go ahead and
completely break this so let's just say
he's on version 5.2 dot 0 I'll just go
ahead and save this okay I don't need to
demo angular yeah it's fine nobody's
gonna look at that and then you can see
here that it's telling us that we have
an invalid package installed here so
this is the NPM module that's telling us
you're referencing a version that you
don't have so that it can it can smartly
look through your folder look
through the dependencies that you have
and then visually tell you if you have
any problems how many times have you
opened a project and then tried to run
it and gone it doesn't work and they're
like oh I didn't do an NPM install this
package will or extension will help you
by showing you visually what's going on
there so if I opened up this file and I
had like a hundred green squiggly lines
in there that'd be a great indication if
I need to run NPM install exactly and
then the other thing that this package
will do is I think we already went over
allowing two launcher commands one of
the things that I wanted to show you
that's sort of an NPM hack not really to
do with Visual Studio code but Elijah
manor showed me this and it changed my
life because it's the simplest thing in
the world so I'm gonna go to a terminal
session remember we can do control
backtick there to open that up so if we
wanted to do I tell you what let's do
I'm gonna go up a directory let's do a
new directory oh I'm gonna get directory
now it's weird so let's do directory
Berk and then we'll move into Berk and
let's say we want to initialize a new
project in here so we would do NPM and
NIT and then it's gonna start asking us
a ton of questions and normally we just
do this right here right we're like
whoever captures all those questions and
I'm done all right I do this almost
every single day so let's do this remove
that file what we can do instead is we
can just say NPM an it
- why enter and boom it just answers all
of them for you so everybody thank
Elisha Manor for that tip that's
directly from him that will save you a
ton of time so that's intellisense
inside of package.json files that is the
NPM module and that is an extra special
bonus tip just for creating your package
JSON files Thank You Elijah I don't know
what you changed again let's go to undo
that that's gonna be a habit today there
we go
by the way I got a little green
underline there right it's saying hey
angular Commons extraneous it's not like
an opinion that it has about it
definitely got an opinion it's like
today I don't like you so one thing you
can do in here man remember you can
reload the window so I can hit command
or reload it and let's hopefully make
sure the squigglies go away sometimes
that kind of thing happens seems okay
right now so Burke just created a file
right inside was it Burke yes all right
so let's go oops that's not where I
wanted to be down here let's go back and
let's go inside of Burke that's really
scary
so I'm looking inside your head yes
I'm scared there's not much there it's
like the lego movie yes and then we're
looking we see a package.json but maybe
I want it to load that in this project
remember ice I could type in code I have
a shortcut for C because I'm really
efficient it's 25% of the time to type
it so I type in C and I could do C dot
that would open up a new instance of
code because this is just a terminal
what if I want to stay in this instance
I can do - R it means I really want to
stay here so I can type that and it's
going to go open that folder in this
instance of V s code right here so
you're not opening a second instance so
there's flags on this it'll allow you to
launch the same thing and if you look
through here I only have one instance of
V s code running and you can see hey
there's some own again hi Simona up and
on my machine so now I want to get back
into there I can go back into my
terminal and we're gonna go back out
we're gonna go into my git folder and
then I can also do I forgot what was
called lose Vikings yeah that was
Vikings is that I could do C - r go back
in its gonna reload and one other thing
to show with NPM which I find a wicked
cool is a relatively new feature notice
there's this thing called NPM scripts
you gotta say it like that this is going
to show you all the scripts that are
inside your package JSON and then you
could run these things like hey tests I
bet you they don't work but I could
right-click it and I could choose run
and it's gonna go ahead open up the
terminal it's gonna run my tests I'm
pretty sure they're all gonna fail
because I have not changed them for
angular 6 yet but it's gonna run over
there but that's kind of nice because
alternatively what would we do we'd open
up the terminal run NPM test do it
ourselves or
and I'll kill this one here boom boom or
we could go up to NPM run script and we
could choose test right from the menu so
there's multiple ways to solve the same
problem it really depends on how you
like to roll if you like the keyboard
track keyboard you can use the commands
you can use the terminal or you can use
the trackpad and right click over here
inside of your NPM scripts yes you can
see how we're just sort of move
the slider this whole session we just
moving it from text editor and we're
moving closer and closer and closer to
IDE so as we move closer to IDE I want
to talk about some features that you're
gonna find more inside of an IDE because
that's the direction that we're headed
here one of the things that I always
loved about visual studio I was a.net
developer for a short time and I was a
terrible one and you're all lucky that I
don't do that anymore
but one of the things that I really
liked about Visual Studio was that the
database tooling was right inside of the
IDE you didn't really need to go to the
management studio it was just there so
if you wanted to run a query if you
wanted to create a table if you wanted
to test all of that was there and that's
really the defining feature of an
integrated development environment is
that all of the development things that
you need are integrated in and so one of
the things that you can use inside of
Visual Studio code is something called
the cosmos DB extension now the cosmos
DB extension connects to Azure cosmos DB
was a lot about that in the keynote it's
a fantastic database but one of the
little-known things about Azure cosmos
DB or the extension rather is that it
will connect to any [ __ ] DB instance
that you have so in this case John's got
one running his localhost here you can
see that but this will connect to any
any [ __ ] installation running available
on the [ __ ] DB slash slash colon slash
slash protocol and there's no security
so you can hit any database in the
entire world that's right look at you
you have the key thing keys of the
kingdom kidding and then you can see
your collections inside of that so if we
click on this we can see the different
documents if I was to right-click on
this and say open collection we can see
all of the data over here on the other
side now that's really nice it allows us
to move through our data but remember we
talked about having an integrated
development environment where you can do
things like test queries so a lot of
times when we're developing is the
database we need a tool that allows to
go in and write and test our queries we
can do that inside of Visual Studio code
so command shift P opens the command
palette and we're just gonna look for a
[ __ ] scrapbook so I'm going to do new
[ __ ] scrapbook here and you can see
over here on the side that it says that
we're connected right here to this
instance so at this point we're just
using straight MongoDB and we can come
over here on the side and I hit DB like
this and a dot and I get intellisense
built into Visual Studio that tells me
what my collections are so we'll do the
hero's collection here and then I'll hit
a dot again and it tells me here are all
the [ __ ] commands that you can run
against this collection all with inside
of Visual Studio code so I can do find
like this and then if I want to execute
this I got a couple different options I
can do command shift P and just say
execute command execute MongoDB command
like this and there we go
or you close that let's not do that
let's close this we can do command shift
and then double quotes and that will do
the exact same thing so you can test out
all of the different commands that you
have all of your different [ __ ] queries
without having to install a [ __ ] DB
admin tool all from with inside Visual
Studio code and if you're using cosmos
TV you get a whole host of other stuff
as well things like access to the key
value store and the graph API and things
like that there was a session Matt
Hernandez did a session covering that in
more detail so if you missed that one I
think you should be able to check out
the recording on that we have links to
those other sessions correct at the end
of the slides yes very cool show that
one yeah we want to do that when you
have a JavaScript file we can look out
here no but you can make one all right
sounds good
actually you know what let's do you got
dia of functions installed I want to
talk about that one to you as our edger
functions this is another really cool
one again we're talking about making
visual studio code in IDE so the azure
functions extension is an extension for
visual studio code that allows you to
very very easily work with Azure
functions create them run them test them
debug them and even deploy them so in
this case if we wanted to create a new
add your functions project I can click
on this folder here and it's gonna ask
us where so we'll just do a new folder
here and I'm gonna I'm just gonna sorry
John I'm completely ruining your I'm
just gonna watch so I know today we'll
clean it it's functions demo we'll
select that and then we're gonna select
a JavaScript function type here because
we've already talked about what a
terrible c-sharp developer I am you do
not want me writing that so we'll click
that and it's going to go ahead and it's
to create a new project for us inside of
that folder here and then what we can do
is we can come and create a new function
a new Azure function inside of that
folder and those are functions could be
blob triggers or cue triggers or timer
triggers HTTP triggers are probably the
ones that we use most often as web
developers was because we're familiar
with how to do that so let's see did
let's see if we can open it here let's
do you open see if we can find our was
what was called Vikings and I think I
put it inside of a folder called
functions demo yeah there we are so
let's open that we won't save any of
that there we go so now our functions
project is open here and if we wanted to
create a new function just come down to
our what do they call these things it's
called Christmas the name of these
little sections here
explorers done this I always call them
the wrong thing I'm like this pane all
this blade no that's not right explorers
click the little lightning bolt and
we'll say that we want to use the
current folder that we're in and then
wants to know well what sort of a
trigger do you want let's say we want to
do an HTTP trigger like this and we'll
just call it hello build like this will
do anonymous because who needs security
and then we've got a function here and
we can go ahead and run this by coming
to the debug hitting the play button and
this will go ahead and fire up our
function locally and then we can just
click let's go back to our terminal
you'll see the URL here and we can just
hit it like this and boom you're already
writing as your functions that's all you
have to do to create an azure function
that's all you have to know and then
when you're ready to actually publish
your add your function let's disconnect
this you can just come over here to your
section and as your functions down here
and you can just hit this button right
here and you can deploy directly from
visual studio code and you can also
create your functions project directly
from visual studio code so this is a
really really powerful way to work with
the different features in Azure
there's also extensions for app service
there's extensions for Azure storage
Explorer or as your storage there's
extensions for functions we talked about
that we talked about cosmos dB
am I missing in daugher which occur
there's a doctor extension as well yes
I'll be doing a session later this
afternoon showing a lot of these
different Azure based and node based
extensions building a node app I think
around 1:15 okay
we have I think just two or three more
things you needed to show you one I want
to show the bonus ones make sure we get
time yeah see this one here so this
literally is hot off the presses let's
see if this works I created a new
project Burke doesn't even know what I'm
gonna do what's he gonna do out there oh
my god it's so amazing so I've got this
fascinating project called node 101 it's
a really really big project it's got a
single file and it's a node server
that's it so inside of this file I could
run this right I could go down here and
I could type in node server j/s and
that's nothing with my prompt my file
it's called a node and XJS it's
listening on port 3000 I can come up to
here I can type in localhost 3000 zoom
in and you can see yeah you look it's
not really on Azure yet but you get the
idea so we've got our node server here
that we can run but what if we want to
debug it locally well Burke how do we
debug locally by creating a launch
configuration the launch config so I can
hit this debug thingy over here which is
a bug with a slash through it and I can
just do run right
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo and it's thinking
there we go there we go hey it's like
connection has been refused so I can
debug my stuff through here by launching
up my index file in this case it's
running start to bug why is it having a
problem hmm it's looking for start to
bug so I go into my project notice I
want to start with NPM start so I can
run this by running NPM start but the
secret feature I want to show is there's
a new thing that vs code is now in
preview and I believe the blog post is
coming out today or tomorrow Chris on
this yes chris is the guy who owns this
whole thing so anything that failed
today is his fault
everything's Bert right my reason why my
laptop wouldn't show up on the screen
that's Chris yes yes because vs code
can't do that yet for some reason so
inside of here there's a new feature
where you can actually deploy your app
to Azure and then debug it from vs code
think about that for a second you can
write your code here deploy at the azure
and then debug it right from vs code so
I had something open up here I think I
called it node build node 101 as your
website's let's zoom in because that's
way too small this is a live site you
can all hit it it's an amazing website
that I wrote up on Azure and if I wanted
to debug this what I could do is I have
to set an NPM script and I'm calling it
start a debug it's just a convention
we're using right now you can eat
whatever you want I've then told a sure
that this is what its gonna run so it
knows to run that and I'm not just
running node index I'm running it with
the inspection flag so it knows it's
gonna use the debugger and there's a
special environment variable here that
we're gonna set this is all gonna
explain a blog post it's going to be
coming out soon and how this works and
the app services team too so when I set
all this then what I can do is come back
to my project and you notice I have some
options here I could deploy to a web app
I've done that you just saw it actually
running well now over in the azure pane
i've got the app service extension i
could open up john papa
hey we opened berkeley for and inside of
here you can see I've got build node 101
if I right-click on that there's a new
feature down here called start remote
debugging who wants to try it Chris it's
gonna work right he says I hope so
this is literally just happened and look
at that we've got a debugger and we hit
a breakpoint whoa but wait there's more
so we're inside of here and notice we're
stopped here but I'm trying to inspect
Reds and stuff and I want to break
inside of this it broke inside of an
asynchronous callback that's really cool
so normally when you want to break
inside one of these callbacks you've got
to change your code but curly braces
there and then go back and put the
breakpoint I've done that what would
have then happened then is I'd have to
save my code and redeploy at the azure
and then retry it and I don't really
want to do that so we can right-click
inside of our code and then we can
choose this option down here addict
breakpoint I've already selected that
and that's why it's changing it there so
now I can see the messages hello from
Azure I can come over here to my code I
could change get rid of some of these
guys I could come down to my code and I
could look through and I could change
the request I could let it run through
and if I want to I can change the
message and we could change what happens
up top that's pretty cool and it's
guaranteed to work Chris Diaz said so
you just saw it not something I think I
would do for a production code but if I
wanted to bug something live on Azure
super easy cuz hey every time you run
code locally it always works on another
machine right yeah so Brooke we have one
last tip what you got we talked about
this thing called a multi cursor have
you ever had a project let me go back to
my Vikings you ever had a project where
you wanted to grab something out of
someone's package JSON and you want to
just grab just what those packages were
like maybe I want to grab just the
angular stuff here and I want to go
install those so what I could do is I
could grab all these files here I'm
gonna open a new file with command n
just an empty file I'm gonna paste what
I really want to do is end up with
something that looks like NPM install
and then all those packages so I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna go through and I'm
gonna highlight whatever I see is common
throughout them all maybe they're not
all starting with angular in this case
they are but I'm going to grab the quote
comma colon space quote now I'm gonna
hit command D and you'll notice the
cursor is moving down the line finding
every match that I've got I can then
delete those I'm holding command shift
right arrow go to the end of the line
deleting those command left deleting the
comma at the beginning now I'm gonna go
to command right to go to the end I'm
then going to put a space in there I can
go back I can now go to the end of line
front and now I can go and head and
space them all out go to the end I can
type in - save now you can send that
command to your friends you can run it
at a terminal copy and paste it and do
it this is super powerful it's called a
multi cursor it allows you to edit
multiple lines of code all at the same
time it's one of my favorite features
that was in sublime and I wouldn't use
the ESCO til it was there and
these guys put it in and it's pretty
awesome alright let's flip back to
slides those red lights blinking my
anxiety levels going through the roof
all right
at a time where do they go to find all
these tips we've got so first of all the
slides are gonna be available all of the
tips that we gave you are gonna be an
image and gif format in the slide so you
don't have to remember any of this stuff
just know that you can do it go back and
research in your own time here are all
of the different resources that we've
got for you in terms of us code the
angular essentials package from John the
extensions marketplace node extensions
everybody took their pictures they're
grainy pictures all right
there's a lot of Visual Studio code at
build so if you're interested in more
here's some of the other sessions that
we've still got that you can go to I'd
recommend checking those out there's
gonna be a lot of Visual Studio code for
the next couple of days we'd like to
thank you for joining us this morning
you had allotted a lot of choices
[Applause]